اثار قرار مجلس محافظه صلاح الدين
العراقيه اعتبار المحافظه اقليما مستقلا
اداريا وماليا اثر جدلا في الاوساط
العراقيه بشان دوافع هذه الخطوه ومدى
انسجامها مع الدستور وقد تفاعل القرار
بثوره اكبر مع تلويح محافظه الانبار اتخاذ
اجراء مماثل ما لم تسارع الحكومه العراقيه
الى اطلاق سراح المعتقلين من ابناء
المحافظه في مهله لا تزيد على ثمان
واربعين ساعه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما هي دوافع هذه التوجهات
الاستقلاليه وما مدى انسجامها مع مواد
الدستور العراقيه
وما مدى تاثير هذه التحركات على وحده
العراق وما هي خيارات الحكومه حيلتك
دخلت الساحه العراقيه في جدل جديد بعد
قرار مجلس محافظه صلاح الدين تحويل
المحافظه الى اقليم مستقل اداريا وماليا
وبينما ينتظر ان يرفع مجلس المحافظه قراره
هذا الى مجلس الوزراء سارع رئيس الحكومه
نور المالك الى رفض الطلب مسبقا قائلا ان
هذه الخطوه ذات دوافع طائفيه من جانب قال
رئيس اللجنه القانونيه في البرلمان
العراقي ان الاستطاعه مجلس المحافظه
اللجوء الى المحكمه الاتحاديه اذا ما عرقل
المالكي قرار المحافظه
يخص الدستور العراقي الاقاليم دون
المحافظات بجمله امتيازات اهمها زياده
المخصصات الماليه والحق في وضع دستور
الخاص وتاسيس حكومه وبرلمان وجهاز قضائي
مستقل فضلا عن الحق في انشاء وتنظيم قوى
الامن الداخلي كالشرطه والامن التي تقع
بالطبع تحت ولايه حكومه الاقليم وليس
الحكومه الاتحاديه كما هو الوضع في حاله
المحافظه ووفقا للدستور نفسه فانه لا يحول
بين ابناء المحافظات وهذه المميزات سوى
تغيير اسم حيزهم الجغرافي من محافظه الى
اقليم انطلاقا من هذا الوضع وهربا من
تهميش حكومه المالك واعتقالاتها المتكرره
بحق ابناء محافظه صلاح الدين كما يقول
قاده المحافظه قرر اعضاء مجلسها بالاجماع
يوم الخميس الماضي الشروع في اجراءات
تخولهم تحويل الصيغه الاداريه التي تعرف
حيزهم الجغرافيه الحالي انه محافظه صلاح
الدين ليصبح بعد اكتمال هذه الاجراءات
اقليم صلاح الدين ينص الدستور على ان ينقل
مجلس المحافظه قرره الى الحكومه المركزيه
التي تحيله بدورها الى مفوضيه الانتخابات
ومن ثم تقوم المفوضيه باستفتاء سكان
الاقليم الذين يقررون دون سواهم ما اذا
كانت منطقتهم ستبقى محافظه امس ستتحول الى
اقليم رئيس الحكومه العراقيه نور المالكي
الذي طالما حرص على ربط خطواته بالدستور
قال ان حكومته لا توافق على تحول محافظه
صلاح الدين الى اقليم معلل الرفضه هذه
الخطوه بانها ان وقعت ستحول هذه البقعه
الى ملاذ امن للارهاب المتمثل في حزب
البعث وتنظيم القاعده لكن المالكي لم يوضح
ما اذا كانت دستور قد كفل له اصلا حق
الاعتراض على قرارات من هذا النوع كما انه
لم يقل ما اذا كان رفضه هذا
تجميده قرار مجلس المحافظه عند مرحله
الحكومه وعدم الدفع به الى مفوضيه
الانتخابات كما ينص على ذلك الدستور
وايما ستكون المسارات التي ستتخذها قضيه
صلاح الدين فان تحديها لن يكون فيما يبدو
الاخيره من نوعه الذي ينتظر المالكي فها
هي الاصوات ترتفع في محافظه
نينوى والانبار مطالبه بالسير في طريق
محافظه صلاح الدين وبدافع من الاسباب
ذاتها على وجه التقريب ولان كان الامر في
اطواره الاولى بمحافظه نينوى فان مجلس
محافظه الانبار الذي ينتقد ما يصفها
بالاعتقالات الواسعه والجائره ضد ابناء
المحافظه امهل المالكي حتى مسائل الاثنين
للتراجع عنها والا فان قرارات مصيريه كما
قال اعضاء مجلس المحافظه سيتم اتخاذها دون
تاخير
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من بغداد عزه
الشيخ بندر عضو ائتلاس دوله القانون ومن
تكريت سبهان الملا رئيس مجلس محافظه صلاح
الدين ومن لندن معنا محمد الشيخ لمدير
المركز الوطني للعداله
وقبل ان نبدا النقاش نتوقف مع المواد
الدستوريه الخاصه بتشكيل الاقاليم في
العراق
اذا نبدا نقاشنا مشاهدينا والبدايه من
بغداد مع عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون عزت
شهبندر سيد شهبندر مجلس محافظه صلاح الدين
استند الى الدستور في تحويل المحافظه الى
اقليم او الطلب بتحويل المحافظه الى اقليم
على ما استند المالك في رفضه هذا طلب
شكرا لك في الحقيقه هذا هو
يعني الفيدراليه حق دستوري وقانوني كفله
الدستور ضمن شروط
معينه وقد اعتمد مجلس المحافظه او يستطيع
ان يعتمد في تقديم هذا الطلب
على قاعده دستوريه ولكن
حينما يقترن هذا الطلب
بجو من الذي نعرف وتعرف حضرتك وكل
المشاهدين
ان رئيس محافظه صلاح الدين يطالب بقطع
الطريق طريق صلاح الدين بغداد
ويهدد بقطع
الامدادات من الوقود والغاز بنسبه 60%
ويهدد بامور اخرى وتجيش
الجماهير في شوارع صلاح الدين كي تخرج
ترفع شعارات
باسقاط المالكي
وترفع علم صدام حسين
نستطيع ان نفهم هذا الطلب
وتوجهاته والمناخ الذي انطلق منه
الفيدراليه حال ايجابيه
يفترض ان نتعامل معها على انها هي خطوه
باتجاه ان التكامل
التكامل بين المركز وبين المحافظات يصير
اداء افضل
وقدرته على تقديم الخدمات افضل
وقدرت على
تاكيد
اواصر التوحد توحد هذا البلد تكون افضل
ولكن حينما يقترن الطلب بجو من هذا النوع
المالكي وغير المالكي وكل الوطنيين
والاحرار والشرفاء في محافظه صلاح الدين
قبل الرفض
هناسي وليس رفض مستند الى اي ماده من مواد
الدستور
القانون قانون والدستور دستور ولكن
القانون والدستور مو بعيدين عن الجانب عن
الجانب السياسي نعم سيد سبهان الملا
استمعت الى السيد عزت شهبندر يتحدث عن
الموضوع
واتهامات لمجلس المحافظه بالتاكيد استمعت
اليها مرتك
تحياتي لكم قناه الجزيره وتحياتي الى
ضيوفك الكرام
ردنا في البدايه انه هذا الاستحقاق هو
استحقاق كفاله الدستور كما اوضحتم واوضح
الاستاذ عزت الشاب بندر
لم نتمتع بهذا الاستقلال منذ ان خرج
القانون ولحد الان لاسباب يعني ربما تتعلق
بحرصنه على ان المركز
سيلملم اطرافه
وسيحل المشكله السياسي في المركز انتظرنا
هذا الانتظار طويلا واي ثمان سنوات من
2003 لحد اليوم المشكله السياسي في المركز
لم يحل ولا توجد افاق لحل والخلافات
تتفاقم يوم ليوم
والقتل والدمار
يوميا يكادان يكون جزء من الحياه اليوميه
الموجوده في العراق
مجلس المحافظه يتكون من ثمان عشر كتل
سياسيه اللي صوتت هي تسع كتل لصالح هذا
القرار ربما الدوافع تختلف من هنا الى هنا
ولكن في كل الاحوال الدوافع الاساسيه اللي
طلبت ان لا تذهب باتجاه السقف العالي
للدستور
وارتظت بان يكون الاقليم اقليم اداري
واقتصادي وامني يعني اقليم غير سياسي
سيد دستور حرصا سيد الملا
بوضوح هو اتهم بانكم هددتم بقطع الطريق
وقطع الغاز عن باقي المناطق تجهيش
الجماهير ورفع علم حزب البعث وغير ذلك
بمعنى ان هناك اهداف سياسيه وهو يقول ايضا
اهداف سبقه للملك ان تحدث ايضا ربما عن
اهداف طائفيه في ذلك
سمعت الحديث
اللي يهدد بقطع كان تصريح من محافظ صلاح
الدين وليس من رئيس المجلس وكان معنا
ابراهيم الوزراء في
تصريح يعني ربما
نمع عن موقف جماهيري ربما كان اكو سوء فهم
للتصريح المهم سيد محافظ صلاح الدين تراجع
عن تصريحه في وقتها واعلن باليوم الثاني
من تجمع في الضلوعيه بان صلاح الدين لا
يمكن ان تتجه بهذا الاتجاه
لا يبرر الخشيه اذا هنا الا يبرر ذلك خشيه
الائتلاف دوله القانون والمالكي
السيد العزيز السيد العزيز السيد دوله
رئيس الوزراء بالامس اتهمنا بانه قد نكون
ملاذنا امنا للبعثيين في حين الاعتقالات
الاخيره اثبتت ان المحافظات الجنوبيه اللي
هي الملان الملاذ الاكثر من البعثيين لانه
اعتقل من صلاح الدين 22 شخص فقط في حين من
محافظه النجف وحدها خمسين شخص ومن البصره
ومن الناصريه ومن الكويت اعداد اكبر من
هذا بكثير فاذا لماذا نتعا بكون ملاذ امن
للبعثيين والبعثيين ما شاء الله في جنوب
العراق ظهر انه تواجدهم اكثر
نعم حسن تحياتي لك ولضيوف الكرام حقيقه
ابتداء دعنا نوضح ان الدستور العراقي لعام
2005 قد بين كما ورد بتقريركم من الماده
116 الى الماده 121 حول موضوع تشكيل
الاقاليم وصلاحيات الاقليم وكيف يتم تشكيل
الاقليم ولكن الدستور العراقي ايضا اقر
وجود اقليم كردستان وهو لم يكن من ضمن
ولايه الدستور العراقي الحالي وانما ما
قبل ولايه هذا الدستور ولكن الدستور اقر
وجود هذا الاقليم كما رسم ايضا تشكيل
الاقاليم الجديده النقطه الاساسيه قبل
الابعاد السياسيه انه
وبعد تحفظنا عن كل هذه الالغام الموجوده
والتي بدات تتفجر من داخل ما يسمى
بالدستور العراقي والتي اشرنا الى تحفظنا
الكبير بها منذ عام 2005 ولكن الان الجميع
يدفع ثمنها ولكن بنفس الحاله ان للاسف
التصرفات التي يدعيها شركاء العمليه
السياسيه بالتصرفات الديكتاتوريه للحكومه
المركزيه ولرئيس الحكومه يدفع هذه
المحافظات وهذه الادارات المحليه الى
الدفاع عن نفسها باتخاذ خطوات دستوريه
موجوده وفق هذا الدستور ورسمها هذا
الدستور ومجلس محافظه صلاح الدين لم ياخذ
حقيقه خطوه خارج الاطار الدستوري قدم طلبا
لتشكيل هذا الاقليم بموجب الماده 117 و
118 من الدستور العراقي الحكومه المركزيه
والبرلمان العراقي ليس لديه اي صلاحيه
بمنع او عرقله هذا الطلب المبني الى
الفقرات المشار اليها بالدستور العراقي
ولكن تبقى نتيجه تشكيل الاقليم على
الاستفتاء العام الذي يتم داخل المحافظه
وبالتالي يستطيع سكان المحافظه ان يقرروا
ذلك عن الحكومه المركزية هذه
الاليه معروفه لكن السؤال يعني في البعد
السياسي للموضوع حتى لا نترك الموضوع في
اطاره الضيع الداخلي والعناوين
التهميشيه التي يحكى عنها
نعم حسن حقيقه انت تعلم بان مع قرب ادعاء
انسحاب القوات الامريكيه من العراق هنالك
تدخلات كبيره بالشان العراقي من قبل دول
الاقليم وعلى راسها بالتاكيد ايران لانها
سبق وان رفعت شعار ملء الفراغ وسد الفراغ
داخل العراق انتم تعلمون ان الازرع
الموجوده للحكومه الايرانيه داخل العراق
هي اذرع اخطبوط حقيقه قاتل للشعب العراقي
وجميع ابناء الشعب العراقي شماله وجنوبه
وسط يدفعون ثمن التدخل الايراني هذا حقيقه
يجعل بعض المحافظات حتى تاخذ
بالتحوط الاستباقي لاي مد ايراني داخل
العراق جعل هذه المحافظات ان تحاول ان
تحفظ وتدافع عن صلاحيات المحافظه عن شعب
هذه المحافظه والنقطه الاساسيه ان تصرفات
الحكومه الاخيره خاصه بالاعتقالات
والاقصاء وتفعيل بهيئه المساءله والعداله
ووضع كثير من الاساتذه والكفاءات العراقيه
على قائمه الاقصاء هذا ما يجعل بعض
المحافظات حقيقه ان تحاول ان تشكل سدا
منيعا اتجاه الحكومه المركزيه
الحكومه المركزيه في التصرف مع هذه
المحافظه او تلك فوجدنا هنالك كثير من
المشاهد في ذلك الاعتقالات التي تتم خارج
التشاور مع مجالس المحافظات يتم جلب
المواطنين من المحافظات العراقيه بواسطه
المركزيه بدون التشاور هذا الموضوع سلطات
المحليه والقضائيه سناتي على ذكر هذا
الموضوع سيد الشيخ لي في الجزء الثاني من
حلقتنا هذه والتي نسال فيها عن مدى تاثير
هذه التحركات على وحده العراق وخيارات
الحكومه العراقيه حيال ذلك انتظر انتظرونا
مشاهدينا بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في حلقتنا التي
تتناول دوافع وتداعيات قرار محافظه صلاح
الدين العراقيه بتحويل المحافظه الى اقليم
مستقل واعود الى ضيف من بغداد عزتندر عضو
ائتلاف دوله القانون سيدي شابندر قبلكم
بالدستور ومضامينه ها انتم تدفعون ثمن
سياساتكم التهميشيه ادت الى ما نشاهده
اليوم ومن حق المحافظات ان تتحوط تجاه
الاذرع الايرانيه بعد الانسحاب الامريكي
ما رايكم في ذلك
يعني اولا لم يجب احد من الاخوين الكريمين
على اسئلتك
سمعت من الاخ من لندن يعني خطبه اسماء في
الحقيقه في موضوع انا ما فهمت شيء سواء
الاقصاء
والتهميش ومشاكل ولكن لم يعطيني شاهد واحد
على هذا الاقصاء وعلى هذا التهميش هناك
رغبه في شل المركز والحكومه المركزيه
هناك دوافع انت حلقه حضرتك هي الدوافع
والتداعيات يعني انا اشوف اخونا متحمس جدا
ضد ايران
واحنا ضد التدخل الايراني بشكل واضح ولكن
لم يرف له جفن والمدفعيه التركيه اليوم
تدك ارض كردستان العراق
وتهدم وتهدم المنازل والابنيه على رؤوس
ابنائها في قرى
كرديه عراقيه بريئه ولكن هو نصب عينه
التدخل الايراني اللي احنا والحكومه
المركزيه ان دين قبله
ونعمل على تقليم اظافر هذا التدخل واي
تدخل اخر من هذا النفس تفهم انت العفوان
الطائفي قديش هو احد اهم الدوافع
لانشاء اقليم من هذا النوع انا من كلام
الاخوين استطيع ان افهم شيء واحد فقط دون
سواه ان الفيدراليه او او الطلب بان يكون
لصلاح الدين اقليم هو مو الخيار الوطني
الاول
الخيار الوطني الاول هو ان تمضي الحاله
كما هي في العراق الان من وحده اراديه
ومزيد من الصلاحيات للمحافظات والحكومات
المحليه
ومزيد من تنسيق وترشيق العلاقه بين المركز
وبين الاقليم ولكن نتيجه للاقصاء المتصور
والظلم والاضطهاد والدكتاتوريه هم يختارون
الاقليم ولذلك نحن نحتاج في الحقيقه الى
بسط الدليل على ان هناك ظلم وتهميش واخفاء
هل ان يتحدثون عنه العسكريه والاعتقالات
ويعني الكثير من مراكز الدوله التي لم يتم
اعطاء سكان هذه المناطق حقهم فيها هم
يتحدثون بالكثير من النقاط عن تهويش
المعتمده بارك الله بارك الله فيك هو الاخ
يقول الاعتقالات
كانت في المحافظات الجنوبيه اللي هي 650
معتقل 22/1 فقط من صلاح الدين هو نفسه
يقول وهذا الدليل على ان الاعتقال دوافع
السياسيه وليست طائفيه كما هو يصور بس هو
موجوع لان المعتقلين بعثيين ولكن يراد ان
يلبس هذا الاعتقال وهذا الاجراء الامني
القانوني والدستوري يلبسه ثوب الطائفيه لا
توجد طائفيه لدى الحكومه العراقيه اما
المناقلات بس خليني اكمل في جامعه صلاح
الاختصار
نعم عفوا
يعني
قص قصه هذه ما حصل في جامعه صلاح الدين
الذي حضرتك وكل المشاهدين والاخوه
المتحمسين ايضا بلا دليل ان يعرفون حقيقه
هذا الموضوع اللي هم مقصودين بقرار وزير
التعليم العالي هم 140 سته منهم دكتوراه
نعم
اريد اريد
عفوا اعتذر منك سيد عزت اريد من سبهان
الملا رد على ذلك وانت استمعت الى السيد
شهبندر يتحدث ردا على ما اوردته سيد سبهان
تفضل
استاذي العزيز واخي العزيز عزه الشابندر
والاخوان الاعزاء جميعا
محافظه صلاح الدين
لم تلبس او لم مجلس محافظه صلاح الدين لم
يلبس
قراره الى ثوب البعثيه او ثوب الطائفيه
ومشاكل بل القرار كان واضح جدا انه نريد
التوجه لم نتهم احدا بالطائفيه
للعلم لا الحكومه المركزيه هاي حكومتنا
واحنا جزء منها الكتل السياسيه في بغداد
انا قلت في بدايه حديثي هذا المشكله
السياسيه موجوده في بغداد من 2003 لحد
اليوم لم تحل ولا توجد افاق لحلها فلياس
دفعنا بهذا الاتجاه فعلا مثل ما قال
الاستاذ عزت الشابندر هو ليس الخيار
الوطني الاول لكن هذا الخيار الوطني
البديل الذي لجانا الى للمحافظه على الناس
الانتخابونه
وللمحافظه على لقمه عيش هؤلاء الناس لذلك
رحنا باتجاه اقليم اداري واقتصادي وليس
اقليم سياسي انا اشكرك جزيلا
بس دقيقه واحده دقيقه واحده قبلها
الاستفاده هي مو يعني محدده في جامعه
تكريت قياده شرطه صلاح الدين بعد ان استقر
الوضع الامني يعني هناك الكثير من الماخذ
لديكم على الحكومه لكن اعتذر الوقت لم يعد
يسمح واعتذر كثيرا ايضا من السيد محمد
الشيخ لمدير المركز الوطني للعداله من
لندن لم نتمكن من اخذ رايه في هذا الجزء
ايضا لضيق الوقت شكرا جزيلا لضيوفي من
بغداد عزت الشيخ بندر سبهان الملا من
تكريت ومحمد الشيخ من لندن
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء